this brings up the the right-wing
resistance to transgenderism after the
movement of transgenderism to a lot of
the activism that comes out of it I
think a lot of it is about the pronouns
and I struggle with this myself I don't
know which to use because my reason
tells me just as you said you know you
you're born a man you'll die a man but
you now more resemble you were certainly
resemble a woman you don't look like a
man so my reason tells me it would be
[Music]
objecting to reality to say she and yet
you're my guest you're my friend you're
my politeness would object to calling
you he you and you you and and obviously
in terms of secondary sex trait its you
you certainly look much more like a
woman how do we resolve this this issue
between manners and politeness and civil
society and the biological facts of sex
would you certainly don't legislate it I
think that's a huge problem I was just
reading the other day and 2018 there's
about to be like harsher penalties for
misgendering someone in the health field
than for spreading HIV which is insane
that's right I saw that there making it
will no longer be a felony to
intentionally excuse me to intentionally
spread HIV
California the master liters yeah just a
mess but again you don't legislate it
because that turns people off in it it
also creates trans people makes trans
people a liability when they become
employees you know no company wants to
hire someone who is potentially a
lawsuit you know what I mean so that's a
problem and that's another thing it's
like a double sided swore because
they're trans activists claim to fight
for trans unemployment and then they do
things like that um but again it with
pronouns it's like it just do what makes
sense you know what I mean like for
instance if you and I were to go to
dinner or something
and I got there before you used Oz at
the table and you told people at the
front like I'm meeting my friend you
wouldn't say he's in the black top yeah
that's right because they were using
Sookie dresser for someone else right so
it's just about what makes sense um
unfortunately there are a lot of people
who seem hell-bent on having things not
make sense you know what I mean people
who want to be referred to you with you
know third pronouns fourth pronouns is a
singular day is the worst one that that
is unforgivable it is such an offense to
grammar I can't imagine it and it's
frustrating for me when I'm in those
situations I just don't hang out people
like that if I'm around them I'm not
going to be intentionally rude or
anything but I would prefer not to hang
out with someone who has like that high
of expectations for a normal
conversation with them it's kind of
annoying but other than that just do
what make sense
is there a worry that the pronouns kind
of give up the the premises so in the
pronouns in any polite society you would
just say she and her to refer to you you
you identify as a woman you look like a
woman just go with it
but is there something to worry about
that in that premise by granting the
premise that one can change biological
sex from male to female from him to her
that we're giving the left a a premise
from which many of their arguments will
flow even if it's not a correct premise
does that make sense I didn't say that
articulate no it makes absolute sense um
I guess in a sense but at the same time
it's still about what makes sense I mean
I don't even think it's giving the left
that I think they already have that
they're gonna take it yeah
you against it when the reality is like
I don't think since I was a teenager
I've ever been called heat like even
like pre-transition when I was starting
to grow my hair out didn't know her
loans no surgery I still never got
called Pete see what I mean so it's it's
just about common sense obviously when
it comes to some people there's this one
trans activist I believe her name is
Danielle Moscato
I think it's Daniel Moscato and she's
made like no I'm saying she cuz I'm
polite but she's made no attempt to do
anything like literally male clothes
bald head no makeup no anything no in
every way no legal gender and every way
it looks manlier than you like well I'll
take it you know unfortunately there are
a lot of guys who look manlier than me
and so when it comes people like that is
very frustrating um because they'll make
a huge deal about it but most trans
people we have to remember like the
Internet is like not real life so in
mind yeah a lot of these documents like
yeah there's crazy nuts on the internet
but most trans people orders this
doesn't doesn't doesn't matter of course
and and also there weren't that many
transgender people you know the the
statistic for a long time was he was
point two percent of the population or
even less now that some surveys say that
number is point six percent of the
population I think obviously there are
differing numbers because it's such a
small population uh-huh and yet it's all
anyone's talking about and I do think
that the left has made us so reactionary
on this you know I thought they do this
on everything they've but they've
incredibly made crossdressers not fun I
don't know how they did that cross
dressers have always been fun throughout
all of his yeah it makes it like somber
think makes the the village in New York
like this very serious social you know
come on man they've done it on college
campuses they've made sex boring I don't
know how they did that yeah I've always
said like yeah they've always said you
know transgenderism is and should exist
outside of the normal politics because
it's not political it's biological it's
neurological
it's a conditioned psychological yeah
and when you start politicizing things
like that I mean it would suck just as
much if they started politicizing
I don't know autistic people are
something right right you know making a
group of people who are going through
enough like the political football is
really frustrating